dr anthony fauci chief medical advisor
to president biden and the top
infectious disease doctor at the
national institutes of health joins us
now from washington
dr fauci good morning to you we have a
lot to talk about in terms of future
response to the pandemic
but because both you and dr burks gave
reflective interviews recently
i want to start with the recent past dr
burks told face the nation yesterday
that
it is a terminal event in her career
working on president trump's coronavirus
task force she's going to retire
how do you think her work should be
remembered
well she was really you know putting an
incredible amount of herself
into this under very very difficult
circumstances the difference between the
situation i was in and she was in she
had to essentially
live in the white house that's where her
office was
and when she was trying with the team
myself and dr redfield and others
to try and get the medical public health
issues on the table
and addressed there were a lot of
opposing forces
there and it was a very difficult
experience for her i thought she
articulated it
really well in the interview that she
had
where you know particularly when
situations when people
like scott atlas came into the white
house who essentially
was the antithesis of what she was
trying to do and it made it very very
difficult for her so that's what i think
she meant when she said it was a
terminal event
she said that there were two streams of
data
moving to the desk of president trump in
addition she said there was no
full-time team inside the white house
working on the coronavirus two alarming
bits of information i hadn't heard
before
what was your reaction to that
well you know i lived through it with us
so it was
just shaking my head saying yes right
well first of all there wasn't a
full-time
team i mean she was you know getting up
at three o'clock in the morning
collecting the data
presenting it to people but i think the
important point that she made that
really is critical
was the two opposing forces because she
was trying to get
information into the president on a
regular basis but
the president was getting information
from other sources you know
friends on the outside who would call
him up or people who would
who would have input into it and that
gradually attenuated her influence to
the point where she didn't really see
him very much anymore
that's what she was trying to explain
right you said the one million doses per
day
in the first 100 days was a floor not a
ceiling
just doing some simple arithmetic myself
to get to 70 to 85 percent
vaccinated americans by the end of the
summer early fall we would need to be at
about twice the rate
we currently are at 1 million a day and
the goal of the biden administration
so when you talk about a ceiling is 2
million a day plus
is that possible based on what you see
so far
no i think it is you know if you listen
to what the president said he said we're
going to try and get as many doses into
people
as we possibly can as quickly as we can
he set a goal
a little bit ago and and you know
hopefully we'll meet and
surpass that goal that's the point i
mean
is it only just because someone gives
just be i hope hope is not i just i
hope is an odd thing to lean on at this
point i mean can we do it
do we have the the manufacturing coming
online do the executive orders from last
week the defense production act does
that
help us reach that goal and and how
yes yes and yes yes we can reach it
he set an original goal of a hundred
million doses in the first hundred days
and as i've said and others have said
that's a floor
not a ceiling it's a reasonable goal
it's not you know it's not easy
to get doses from where you go in the
vial
all through the transportation into
people's arms particularly
when you get out of the realm of giving
it in a hospital
or giving it a nursing home and you've
got to go out into the community
particularly
underserved communities to get it to
people so if people think that's easy
it's not
it gets hard and it'll get harder do we
think we can do it
absolutely we think we can do it let's
touch on the travel ban because the
reporting we have is that today the
biden administration joe biden himself
will announce restrictions on travelers
coming into the u.s from uh the uk and
also crucially south africa where there
is a
mutation that uh scientists are
concerned about
how effective do you think a travel ban
will be
given we recall president trump
instituted a travel ban on china
and it didn't seem to work out too well
well first of all it clearly will be
helpful we
we have concern about the mutation
that's in south africa we're looking at
it very actively
it is clearly a different and more
ominous than the one
in the uk and i think it's very prudent
to restrict travel of non-citizens but
there's also
something else that we didn't have
before is that people coming into the
country are going to be required
to have a test before they get on the
plane
when they get off the plane and land
here they're going to have to have
a quarantine as well as a second test
if i can give you a touch of good news
as you go dr fouchon we appreciate you
coming
spring training starts in three weeks
baseball season is on its way
thank you very much yes thank you
thanks a lot good to be with you